abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
Efe Merhaba Hoş geldiniz
ya ben bugün kendimden çok
bahsetmeyeceğim çok kısa bahsedeceğim
Efem Ben bilim işçisiyim bu kelimeyi çok
düşündüm bilim işçisi olmak işçilik
ustalık yolundaki ilk adımı Belki de
ustalıkla uzmanlık arasında koca bir
fark var uzmanlık e o konunun en Yetkin
kişi olmak ama ustalık o konuyu diğer
konularla birleştire bilmek ve ustalıkta
alıştırma çok önemli Zira ustalık
alıştırma ile kazanılır Ben birimi
uygulama ile beraber ele almaya çalışan
işçilerden bir isim bugün çokluk
dünyasında azlığın içine girmeye
çalıştığımız yeni evrene ilişkin bir
şeyler anlatmaya geldim buraya ve
anlattıklarımın hepsinin sonunda biraz
Kanıt biraz ispat biraz Bu duygu ve
sonuç ortaya çıkarmaya çalışacağız Evet
hızlı bir şekilde şimdi kıymeti
katılımcılar Ben bir Mercedes'i
Üniversitesi'nde çalışıyorum ve başında
olduğum bir birim var bir Merkez var
araştırma merkezine yapıyoruz burada
biliyor musunuz insanı ve insanın
yaşamını klinik deneylere tabi tutuyoruz
şuna bakıyoruz acaba evdeki toz
miktarıyla evlilikteki mutluluk
arasındaki ilişki nasıl
acaba insanların spor yapmasıyla
özgüveni Hatta alışveriş yapması ile
özgüveni arasında birtakım ilişkilerden
bahsedebilir miyiz Hatta stresle evlilik
arasındaki ilişki düzeyi nedir bunlar
gruplara göre nasıl değişiyor hepsinin
sonunda nereyi varıyoruz biliyor musunuz
Eğer çokluk varsa her şey normal her şey
doğal yani
sonucun dikkat bu yararlandığı
durumlarda aynı sonucun çok fazla ortaya
çıktığı durumlara biz normal diyoruz
Tıpkı sokakta aynı giyilen insan aynı
rengi giymiş insanları normal insanlar
dememiz gibi evli insanlar stresi o
kadar çok yaşıyorlar ki evliliğin içinde
stres normal olarak algılanıyor Bizim
ülkede Biz bunu buluyoruz biz
alışverişin Özgüven olduğunu buluyoruz
Çünkü alışveriş yapanların içinde ciddi
miktarda tekrarlanan sayı olarak Özgüven
çıkıyor Peki bu bizi nereye götürüyor
biliyor musunuz normal diye götürüyor
Normal normal ne Aslında
sıraladıktan gayri bir şey değil mi Oysa
normalin üstünde büyük bir basınç var
hem soldan Hem sağdan biz buna birimde
standart sapma diyoruz Yani az görülen
az görülen şey sapmadır eğer az o mavi
saçlı olmaksa sapmadır onlar da o bizim
normal lere baskı yapmaya başlıyorlar
diyor ki bizim sayımız artacak artacak
artacak bizim anormal gördüğünüz şeyler
artmaya başlıyor sapmalar ortalamaya
Küfür etmeye başlıyor ve bunları Eğer
Sürdürülebilir olursa yani
Sürdürülebilir kelimesi Daha doğrusu
konsepti kavramı şu Forum değiştirerek
devam etmek kağıdın geri dönüşümü lefon
değiştirip bardağa dönüşmesi gibi
bardağın form değiştirerek
masaya dönüşmesi gibi birşey Buna da
doğallık diyoruz doğallık fakat Bütün
bunların arasında çokluk normallik
doğallık içinde bizim dikkat etmediğimiz
bir şey çıkıyor başımıza bela olan o de
ne biliyor musunuz Biz tekrar a değer
vermiyoruz tekrarlanan hataları değer
vermiyoruz tekrarlanan güzelliklere
yeteri kadar İyi bari etmiyoruz şu pis
tekrarın önemini çok ihmal ediyoruz Bu
sebeple kıymetli katılımcılar Ben tekrar
çokluk azlık özellik ilişki Bütün
bunların hepsinin karşılığı olan bir
bilim dalıyla uğraşan birey olarak yani
veri bilimi ile uğraşan ama ustalık
yolunda ilerleyen bir işçi olarak içine
azıcık ekonomiyi azıcık sanat azıcık
müzik azıcık iletişim bunların hepsini
katarak bunların hepsini insan ve insan
yaşamında ölçerek hayatımı yürütmeye
çalışıyorum karşımıza şu çıkıyor Buca
siz o halde verebilir misiniz Evet veri
bilimcisi Olmaya mücadelesinde değil
Peki verilebilen bana nasip oldu 2022
itibarıyla Evrensel boyutta ve ülkemizde
verinin ve veriye ilişkini altı Yani top
37 literatürü yeniden yazma lütfunu
görevini nezaketini kıymetini bana
verdiler ve ben bu yeni tanımla kıymeti
katılımcılar verinin
bölünebilen Ama sizler tarafından
algılanan en küçük Sembol olduğunu Dünya
ile uzlaşarak yazdık
veriyi en küçük boyutta indirgenebilen
ama anlamlandırmak kaydıyla Sembol O
halde başka birisi için bir üst boyutta
ama bir başkası için biri için atom biri
için atomun parçası veri bizim hedefimiz
ise en küçükten en büyüğü en büyük küçük
en büyükten en küçüğe Yani geldi gitti
ya da tüm e tümden meselesini çözebilmek
yani bölünebilir hale getirerek on
parçalardan manalar ortaya çıkarabilmek
Böylelikle parçaladığı mızda çok uolu
ama o çoktan aza gelebilmek muhteşem bir
şey heyecan verici birşey o yüzden böyle
bölünebilir semboller tıpo ilk
başladığımız yere geri dönmek gibi hani
o mağaraların duvarlarına e şekiller
çizerler veya semboller İlk başlarda
bize şöyle derlerse marka bir semboldür
vesaire gibi sembollerle ifade edilen
şimdilerde onu birlikte eritmeye
çalışıyor çünkü sapmalar o çoklukları da
değiştirmeye başlıyor o için böyle bir
yolculukta Peki veri bir cümlede ifade
edersek veri sembolize Eğer bir ses Hey
Haluk bir veri ya da benim gömleğimin bu
rengi sizin için biberi hatta çok
enteresan size söyleyeyim bakın burnuma
bir koku geldiğinde annemin çöreği Benim
annem gerçekten güzel çöreği yapardı Tıp
hepinizin annesi gibi
kokuyla annemin çöreği su böreğinin o
güzel görüntüsü arka akan o peynir
dışarıya Taşan peynir var ya muhteşem o
peynir Hatta Annem rahmetli Sabiha
Hanım'ın
fırından çıkarırken onu o fırın tepsi
poğaça eşleşmesi ilişkisi Bunların hepsi
ayrı Sembol ise küçükten büyüğe giden
büyük semboller yani veriler ve bilgi
vesaire kavramından çok daha ötede peki
burada annem yok börek yok aslında
o fırın yok oku Beni bu kadar veriyle
birleştirdi Buyrun sanal gerçek midir
gerçek sana anlatıp
gerçekten ölüp bir başka dünyaya
gideceksek gerçek o mu yoksa biz şu an
burada gerçeği mi yaşıyoruz işte veri
amca bunu çözmek gibi muhteşem bir şey
yapıyor biz bu muhteşem şeyi buradaki ne
anlatmak zorundayız kıymetli
katılımcılar Burada tabii ki işte yumruk
öyle dedi Freud'un yaklaşımı bu planını
Ekol bırakıyoruz Bütün bunların hepsini
hepimiz birer vereyim uzmanız çünkü altı
tane duyumuz altı ayrı veriyi alıyor
bizim tek yapmamız gereken
aldıklarımızı doğru analiz edebilecek
noktaya getirmemiz Yoksa sanal gerçeğe
gerçek sanala karışarak gidecek Bursa
enteresan bir kelime buçuk yıldır çılgın
iki anlamı var biri Gerçek biri sanal
niye Gerçek biri sana alo alo neyin
mücadelesini yapıyoruz biz yapmamız
gereken çok basit sanalla gerçek
arasındaki ayrımı verilen gelen ayırma
yapabilmeniz için bir şeye başvurmak O
da ne biliyor muyuz bilim bilim Çünkü
ispat demek bilim tanıt demek ben bu
gerçek olup olmadığını size kanıtlama
imkanı veren yüzde doksandokuz virgül 78
çok samimi 99 11 78 Hatta
99.999 diye gideni de var E ispatlama
imkanı veren Dolayısıyla biz bu kadar
ispat dünyasında nasıl olur da bize
sadece görsel olarak gelen bir postaki
eski Selin içinde kalan bir küçük
çocuğun gerçek olup olmadığını sorgulama
Yalım Gördüğümüz her şey doğru mu bunu
nasıl test etmeyelim eğer biz bilimi bu
kadar atar daha doğrusu Kanıt
anlayışından bu kadar uzaklaşır Sak
Bence vay halimize ve o yüzden gerçeklik
arayış dünyasında mesele bilimle beraber
gelen kanıtlanabilir
kanıtlanabilirlik
kanıtlanabilirlik leschuk çok önemli
genel olarak sizin inandı O bizim
inandığımız ın inanılmaması gerektiğini
ispatlamak ötekini değil yeni ispatlamak
değil Eskinin inanılmaması gerektiğini
ispatla ya bilmek Yani onun kabul
edilmemesi gerektiğini kabul etmek
bilime pozitif Aslında kabul
edilmemesini
gerektiğine inanmak Evet şimdi böyle bir
durumda kıymetli katılımcılar bizim için
önemli olan tekrar edilebilirlik
nerenin kabullenir edilebileceğini
bilmek ve mevcud um reddedilmesi
mücadelesinde akıllıca davranabilmek
anlamlandırmada İşte bu bizi yeniliğe
götürüyor yenilip kapısı açılıyor
mevcudu kabul etmediğiniz de ortaya yeni
çıkıyor yeni bir yeni çıkıyor yeni bir
yeni çıkıyor Biz buna gelişim ediyoruz
Peki bu çokluk budur bahsettim bu
başımızın belası olan çokluğu 21 21
yılından itibaren radikal bir şekilde
Another place de farklı bir boyuta
geçiriyoruz dünya olarak o da ne en
başta söyleyeyim cümle çokluğu azaltmaya
çalışıyoruz çokluk dünyasından azlık
dünyasına geçmeye çalışıyor iktisadi
sistemler olarak farkında miyiz
bilmiyorum iktisadi sistemler değişiyor
bu iktisadi sistemler de size birçok
ispat verebilirim bu iktisadi sistemler
de çılgın tüketimi bir tarafa bırakmaya
çalışıyoruz hata son zamanlarda Bunu o
kadar arttırma girişimi var ki Çünkü
acilen çokluktan Azra dönmemiz gerekiyor
Eğer azla dönemez sake Yani beş ilişki
yerine Bir ilişkiyle
yetişemezsek 5oda yerine iki odalı bir
evde hayatımızı gayet verimli
geçirebileceğimiz i kavrayamaz Sak bu
yeni Play Senar bu işte işimiz çok zor
acilen Hazırlanıyoruz Biz benim Dünyası
insanları bunu bütün samimiyetimizle
bilimden uzaklaşmadan Ama hayatın içinde
ölçerek kanıta dayalı insan ve insan
yaşamlarını ölçerek örneklerle size
getirmeye çalışıyoruz Çünkü bizim tek
yapmaya çalıştığımız şey var
sadeleştirmek
basitleştirmek değil sadeleştirmek
çokluğu sadeleştirmek bunu nasıl
başaracağız yüksek Sen bir kavram da
muhteşem bir konseptle bu Konsept
muhteşem gelmeyecek Belki ilk duyduğunuz
an çünkü bu kavramı bizim dilimizde çok
iyi bir yere o tutamadık Çünkü dilimizde
o tutamadığımız kavramlar var söylüyorum
çok dikkat ne biliyor musunuz etik etik
birçoğumuz için şu anki böyle bir şey
ifade etmiyor ahlak versem oluyor ama
ahlaktan bahsetmiyorum ettikten
bahsediyorum Bu ne biliyor musunuz
bilimsel olarak çok net tarafların bu
doğru da ya da yanlışta ya da daha
etkileyici bir cümle ile gönderme
yaparak söylüyorum anlaşamamak da dahi
anlaşmak bak ve ona göre davranmak ve
bunu kilo bal yapabilmek bunun için
ciddi mücadeleler Yani şunu diyeceksiniz
Hoca Eninde sonunda başa mı dönüyoruz
diye benim hep sorduğum soruyu kendinize
sorabilirsiniz ahlaklı olmak Hani o ilk
İnsanoğlu vesaire gibi ettik şu davranış
doğru ve yanlışı anlaşma bu bizim
hayatımızı kurtaracak bir nokta
Böylelikle azaltırken Yani bu Esad
eleştirirken basitleştirir Ken değil
sadece eleştirirken
E5 gömlek yerine iki gömleği inerken
arayacaklar ımız uzlaşı olacak uzlaşı bu
bizim için çok önemli ve şuan dünya için
en önemli kavram olan hızlı Ya aslında
bilimin başından bize beri bize değil
ettiği bir şey
fazla yetinebilmek orada uzlaşı
sağlayabilmek ve buradan gelen mutluluk
buradan gelen keyif bir başka cümle
Karşıdaki de varoluş efen ben tekrar
size şunu söylüyorum bilim var olsun
sadelik var olsun kanıta dayalı olsun ve
çokluk dünyasında az lıkla mutlu
olabilmek Yaşasın Saygılarımla